alors convaincus ou pas par ce programme
de construction de nouveaux réacteurs
pour que le président fait un virage à
360 degrés après avoir défendu la
réduction de la part du nucléaire
nucléaire en france quoi qu'il en coûte
on attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme d'ayrté france et place un
autre débat
avec nous pour en parler sur ce plateau
anthony gratacos secrétaire général de
la gauche républicaine et socialistes
bonsoir avec nous également en plateau
alexandre touzet vice-président l ère du
département de l'essonne et puis en
duplex un clodo brender merde fessenheim
sans étiquette ainsi que christophe
grudler député européen modem bonsoir à
tous les deux merci de nous accompagner
claude brenner première question pour
vous quand vous entendez ce virage à 360
degrés
emmanuel macron qui veut prolonger tous
les réacteurs je cite un qui peuvent
l'être au delà de 50 ans si possible
évitez d'en fermer votre centrale on le
sait a était elle fermée comment vous
réagissez ce soir
mes côtés c'est mitigé partagé entre
finalement une bonne une bande annonce
pour le pour le pays pour la filière
nucléaire et puis par contre une prise
de conscience un peu tardive pour pour
notre notre centrale celle de fessenheim
qui a été arrêté par le père ce même
président et qui deux ans après relance
de deux nouveaux réacteurs et donc ces
îles il est vrai que j'attendais une
annonce pour fessenheim pour dire ok
j'ai bien pris le message que fessenheim
a été sacrifiée
finalement aimé mais voilà cette annonce
est pas arrivé mais je ne désespère pas
que facebook puisse avoir un nouvel
essor annuel une nouvelle une nouvelle
perspective de production nucléaire en
france et sur le site de la centrale
christophe grébert vous sautez la
majorité c'est vrai que quand on entend
ce maire qui
m'anime il n'attaque pas trop emmanuel
macron enfin il le dit quand même
fessenheim a été d'une certaine manière
se sacrifier et si on suit la logique du
président de la république elles
n'auraient pas dû l'être
quelle réaction aujourd'hui ce volte
face par toutes les personnes peut-être
qu'ils ont perdu leur emploi à
fessenheim mes côtés pour moi il n'y a
pas de volte-face il y avait une
décision du président hollande dans le
cadre d'une entente avec les verts qui
sont farouchement opposés au nucléaire
donc avant avant 2010 est donc et le
président hollande a programmé la
fermeture de fessenheim qui allait
jusqu'au bout des des processus
évidemment moi je soutiens la filière
nucléaire sous toutes ses formes ce soit
la forme de perd 2,2 est sévère les
voies ya toute une gamme en fait de deux
produits nucléaires qui sont très utiles
à la décarbonation de l'union européenne
et je pense que fessenheim a toute sa
place dans la future écriture on va dire
de des scénarios énergétiques qu'on peut
avoir en france notamment avec toujours
un petit problème pour fessenheim sait
que c'est sur le rhin et que enfin s'il
ya les allemands qui sont profondément
anti nucléaire et qui vont faire encore
une plus grande pression sur la france
pour remettre rien à fessenheim voilà ça
fait partie de la géopolitique c'est un
peu ce que j'ai remis au parlement
européen les relations avec les voisins
etc le voir comment on peut trouver
quelque chose de consensuel mais moi je
pense que pour fessenheim très
clairement les smr peuvent être une
solution on va on va mettre en place une
centrale de small modular réacteur 1
donc les petits réacteur modulaire c'est
certes plus petit mais c'est un produit
d'avenir à autour de 340 mégawatts et
qui peut avoir un intérêt d'être posée
sur un site comme celui fait cela me
anthony gratacos on l'entend oui on se
souvient emmanuel macron qui se targue
d'avoir finalement tenu la promesse de
françois hollande vous essayer à
l'époque au parti socialiste certes un
petit peu frondeur on s'en souvient mais
moi il aurait finalement pas dû se tenir
cette promesse de peur de ceux des jeux
j aujourd'hui
elle était encore réversible quand
emmanuel macron est devenu président de
la république je crois que maintenant
c'est trop tard dans le processus de
démantèlement de la centrale je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse revenir en arrière mais
c'est au delà de la question de
fessenheim de toute façon au président
de la république même si on peut être en
accord avec les annonces qui ont été
faites aujourd'hui et qui sont
courageuses par rapport au contexte
européen à la pression que les allemands
mettent au niveau européen ils viennent
de contester par exemple la taxonomie
européenne qui qui explique clairement
que le nucléaire est une énergie verte
ce que nous nous pensons donc c'est
assez courageux mais il remet absolument
pas en cause tout le système qui nous a
mené
alors d'être là aujourd'hui sur la
privatisation du marché et la
dérégularisation du marché de l'énergie
et sur la destruction d'edf et de gdf
qui nous mène aujourd'hui un problème de
souveraineté en terme en matière
d'énergie alors que c'est au fond le
débat est le sujet le plus important de
ce siècle à la fois pour répondre à la
question du développement durable et de
la protection de l'environnement mais
aussi pour répondre aux questions de
souveraineté parce qu'on le voit avec
l'allemagne qui aujourd'hui prend des
décisions sur la question du gaz russe
qui dépend entièrement de ses intérêts
énergétiques et donc qui n'est plus
totalement souverain je ne veux pas que
la france en arrive à ce genre de
situation demain alors il dit emmanuel
macron effectivement il faut reprendre
le field de la grande aventure du
nucléaire civil un il y revenait
d'ailleurs un petit peu sur ses
adversaires qui affirme que nous
n'aurions pas besoin du nucléaire
alexandre touzet que vous ont évoqué ces
grandes envolées lyriques alors qu'il
disait quand même un petit peu son
contraire effectivement en 2002 17 c'est
un constat d'échec un constat d'échec
que j'ai difficilement nos habitants des
territoires européens robin et que
l'énergie qui augmente un constat
d'échec sur nos paysages parce que ça a
quand même été sa cage france avec ses
éoliennes un constat d'échec en termes
d'indépendance et vous l'avez dit
puisque aujourd'hui dans le cadre des
conflits mondiaux on voit bien que les
états unis sont obligés d'intervenir
pour nous pour que les pays de l'opep
nous délivre un peu plus d'énergie c'est
un sac à chaud un constat d'échec sur
tous les plans et aujourd'hui on a un
effet girouette parce qu'il a pas été
synchro pouvoir ils étaient dix ans au
pouvoir il était secrétaire général de
l'elysée elle était ministre de
l'économie il a été président de la
république et au dernier moment tout
d'un coup on a un volte face alors que
dans la loi aujourd'hui toujours dans la
loi on après on y est inscrit la
limitation à 50 % dans le mix
énergétique du nucléaire y est inscrit
dans la loi la fermeture de centrales
nucléaires tout ça n'a pas changé en
cinq ans donc écouter c'est plus un
président de la république c'est une
girouette face je pense qu'on a un vrai
problème de crédibilité du pays en ce
moment on va justement écouter ce que
vous venez nous décrire un c'est
emmanuel macron le 9 février 2017
nous réduirons notre dépendance à
l'énergie nucléaire avec l'objectif de
50% d'énergie nucléaire à l'horizon 2025
ce n'est pas bon d'avoir 75 % de notre
énergie qui vient du nucléaire
claude brenner clairement aujourd'hui
c'est un aveu d'impuissance aux comédies
avec 112 est un aveu d'échec ont tout
simplement on est en train de découvrir
en france qu'on ne peut pas se passer
pour différentes raisons dont on va
débattre ici mais qu'on ne peut tout
simplement pas se passer du nucléaire
même est clairement on est rené là dans
les limites du mauvais temps c'est à
dire un moment donné et les vrais cons
on attendait nous du président d'un
jeune président et d'un président un peu
pragmatique qui revoit cette promesse de
françois hollande qui remettent ce le
débat sur sur fès m sur le nucléaire sur
la table en début de mandat et pas en
fin de mandat ensuite donc il aurait
très bien pu revenir sur cette décision
d'autant plus que
fait elle a été décorée les de la fed de
l'ouverture de flamanville donc assez
donc c'était quand même bien la volonté
de tenir ses promesses de françois
hollande donc il aurait pu s'en passer
et donc aujourd'hui finalement je
cherchais naturel revient au galop je
dire on pourra pas faire son nucléaire
c'est évident c'est une évidence et on
voit bien l'allemagne qui qui qui à
marche forcée mettre des éoliennes
partout et finalement se retrouve à être
dépendant du gaz de la lignée du charbon
et donc elle est le
leur production électrique élèves et les
4 5 fois su aimer plus de co2 que le mix
français donc cherchez l'erreur ils ont
mis 500 milliards sur la table pour pour
mettre des éoliennes partout pour
saccager leur paysage et de leur pays on
veut pas ça en france je pense que
personne ne veut donc le nucléaire est
incontournable c'est comme ça à matin
dont peut-être la fusion peut-être
d'autres énergies mais pour ce siècle là
il faut en cours de l'énergie nucléaire
c'est évident effectivement christophe
grudler pour ce siècle là c'est ce que
nous dit aussi en substance assez amer
ou yannick jadot qui a exprimé sa colère
avant même qu emmanuel macron prennent
la parole il dit on va s'en prendre
jusqu'à la fin du siècle c'est c'est
ainsi qu'on voit les choses et comme on
lit on n'a pas le choix ça veut dire
qu'on n'a pas eu la bonne vision et les
bonnes stratégies en amont
ou yannick jadot youtube donc dans le
deux mains de futurs éviter de plus
dogmatique chez les écologistes of il y
en a quelques-uns merlus ont fait partie
enfin je veux dire clairement il ne veut
pas nucléaire donc à partir de ce
moment-là vous essayez de tous démontré
pour arriver à cette heure avancée pas
très positif dans ce que je veux
simplement dire c'est qu'il ya pas eu de
volte-face comme j'entends dire quand
même pas monsieur touzet salut approche
peut-être la bouche de dire aujourd'hui
que ce qui est annoncé et bien ça il
pourrait aussi avoir le courage
politique de le dire mais en 2018 le
président la république a commandé des
études énergétiques sur les futurs
énergétique de la france c'était bien
pour savoir vers quoi on devait
s'orienter au niveau énergétique les
scénarios de de rte ont été rendu il ya
quelques mois seulement et disent
clairement que sans nucléaire il n'y a
pas de décarbonation possible de la
france est également d'ailleurs de
l'union européenne donc on a
effectivement besoin du nucléaire on
avait besoin d'un plan d'une vision et l
annonce de 6 e p r tout de suite de huit
encore autres mis en chantier d'ailleurs
c'est sûr que c'est un chantier
monumental de plusieurs dizaines de
milliards mais qui sont indispensables
parce que de production électrique elle
va doubler on va passer 25 % de
production d'électricité dans le mix
énergétique à 55% donc en fait on va
rejoindre davantage de moyens de
production et le moyenne le seul moyen
de production pilotable décarbonée c'est
le nucléaire donc il faut évidemment pas
s'en priver ce que sinon effectivement
ce sont les moyens polluants qui
permettront de réguler l'intermittence
des énergies renouvelables alors
effectivement le nucléaire qui est déjà
très puissant qui représente une grosse
grosse part dans notre pays regardez la
france deuxième pays le plus nucléarisé
au monde quand même après les les états
unis 1 70% de la production
d'électricité
tricolore provient de la tome 4 régions
qui assure plus de 80% de la production
nucléaire alexandre tous et ça ça vous
évoque quoi le deuxième pays le plus
puissant en termes nucléaire après les
états unis il a écouté une grande fierté
moi je suis très heureux quand la france
peut être autonome quand la france est
souveraine quand il ya des savoir faire
industriels et je crois qu'il ya un des
enjeux qui est devant nous c'est la
reconquête de ses savoir faire
industriel ce que je voudrais dire c'est
que en fait sur l'énergie et pour
répondre bon je reconnais des députés
européens on a la même chose qu'elle sur
la sécurité au fond saut à la fin du
mandat qu'on découvre qu'il ya des
problèmes et là tout d'un coup on
s'agite on fait des commissions ont fait
des études gouverner c'est pas ça qui un
temps de réflexion tout le monde ici
peut l'admettre effectivement n'a pas
quand on est candidat forcément tout une
vision on prend connaissance même s'il
était secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée même si les mises l'économie je
pense que il avait quand même à centres
de données mais on décide pas de
l'avenir énergétique de la france
à quelques semaines de la campagne
présidentielle
non mais l'arrière pensée c'est quoi il
était en campagne emmanuel macron ou
peut-être tap l'ukrainienne il se rend
compte que plus que jamais il faut être
indépendant c'est ça mais le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui
ont du reste à vivre dans les milieux
ruraux au père riba parce qu'ils sont
obligés de prendre leur voiture moi
j'habite dans un territoire urbain il ya
un train qui passe de temps en temps je
peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui la
politique des manuels macro on la voit
qu'en france sa voiture on la voit quand
on se chauffe et moi je veux bien qu'on
me dise qu'il a fallu cinq ans pour
étudier le sujet
il ya un petit problème monsieur le
député européen moi je viens vous me
lisez ça moi je gère une commune je suis
vice-président un département je vais
pas cinq ans étudiant un problème sinon
les gens me vire julien il ya un moment
non mais parlez moi mais je pense que
l'action politique doit avoir un lien
avec l'efficacité sinon les plus
crédibles et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
a vraiment un problème de crédibilité et
je le dis et je suis d'accord avec vous
les 6 e pers on le retrouve dans le
programme de valérie pécresse ne veut
pas dire je suis content on le retrouve
mais simplement si vous avez lancé ça il
ya cinq ans eh bien on se serait
retrouvés et je voudrais féliciter mais
aujourd'hui et c'est très malheureux
parce que j'aurais aimé vous féliciter
mais je peux pas le faire parce que le
prix à la pompe élevé puisque le reste à
vivre pour les gens aujourd'hui eh ben
ils voient que ça diminue les filets
travaux d'efficacité énergétique sur les
bâtiments publics c'est particulier ça
pas avancer les transports publics sa
pas suffisamment avancé les énergies
propres alternatifs parce que y'en à la
biomasse le bois etc on n'a pas
suffisamment avancé donc je suis désolé
j'aurais aimé le faire je suis pas dans
une démarche politique mais franchement
établir un diagnostic énergétique de la
france quelques semaines avant
l'élection présidentielle j'aurais du
mal oui à vous féliciter parce que je
serais même pas crédible vis-à-vis de
mes concitoyens la réponse si vous
permettez c'est pas le président qui
décide et sa maintenance irt eux donc le
transporteur public d'électricité
français a mis autant de temps parce
qu'il faut il faut quand même une
expertise très poussée il a fait cette
expertise très poussées il la remet il y
a deux mois au président de la
république c'est public donc tout le
monde voit les différents scénarios il
ya des choix à prendre et un président
de la république responsable qui
gouverne et bien il prend ses décisions
maintenant il se dit pas et la campagne
électorale on va faire un musée on va
présenter de les jolies choses on va se
battre contre mc qui n'ont que des
traces d d d league et céline là il faut
absolument dire non au nom de l'intérêt
national qui est notre souveraineté
énergétique il faut vraiment qu'on
puisse avoir cette capacité à dire
ensemble ok on part là dessus et après
on parle de différences dans le cadre de
la campagne qui va arriver pour tout le
monde très bientôt mais je pense qu'il
faut pas mélanger les choses s'il avait
s'ils n'avaient pas agi vous auriez dit
encore dans le noir il n'a pas été assez
vite que ce qu'il fait il sait rien là
dessus là il agi suite à un rapport qui
vient de lui être rendus et ah ben non
il va trop vite
donc voilà il faut un petit peu être
cohérent sur la lutte contre
l'augmentation des prix je rappelle
comme tous les efforts que tu étais par
bercy par notamment bruno le maire le
gouvernement est donc le présent de la
république pour limiter la hausse des
prix pour les pour les concitoyens et
comme on est dans des campagnes
électorales c'est vrai que l'effort
était supportée par edf voilà on accuse
président de la république d'avoir fait
reporter sa part ed s'il n'avait pas
fait porté par edf on se serait plaint
que les prix auraient augmenté pour les
gens donc assis un moment faut être
cohérent là je pense que ça va vraiment
dans le bon sens il faut lire moi je
suis la majorité présidentielle s'ils
savaient pas dans le bon sens je vous le
dirai avec autant de franchise parce que
j'ai oublié le dogme au parlement
européen ont travaillé un peu avec tous
les groupes politiques est ce que vous
dites ce que vous dites pardon sur la
biomasse sur les autres énergies c'est
le green deal européen qui est en train
d'être terminée au niveau législatif au
mieux au niveau du parlement européen
dans quatre mois on saura tout les
financements pandora notamment pour
l'efficacité énergétique pour
l'isolation des bâtiments pour la
biomasse pour l'intégration de
l'hydrogène dans les transports etc donc
il ya un travail qui se fait un nom avec
des faces un peu juste
pardonnez moi ce que je vais essayer
distribuer la parole équitablement
propos de financement est évident c'est
une question qui se pose
c'est un programme nucléaire d'une
ampleur inégalée depuis 40 ans montant
de ce programme un estimé entre 50 et 60
milliards d'euros sur près de 30 ans
anthony gratacos inquiétez vous sur
justement le financement de ce programme
assez ambitieux mais bien sûr on est
inquiet parce que le président fait des
annonces qui vont plutôt dans le bon
sens mais aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
avec quel moyen le détricotage d'edf gdf
avec sa privatisation aujourd'hui fait
que des faits dans une situation
extrêmement délicate qui à laquelle a
perdu beaucoup en puissance et l'état
lui fait effectivement payé la
libéralisation du marché par exemple on
décide donc elle va vendre moins cher
l'électricité à ses concurrents qui va
la vendre on sait pas pourquoi il existe
ces gens là à part pour faire monter les
prix au final tout le monde se fait
avoir à la fois la société mère car
investi pendant des décennies pour
développer les réseaux les centrales et
c'est le consommateur qui voit les prix
augmenter et l'état qui n'a plus
l'exercice de sa souveraineté via une
politique énergétique efficace et ça il
ne le remet absolument pas en cause
après le débat sur le financement il va
venir avec le temps puisque ça va ça va
se faire petit à petit mais il suffit de
prendre un exemple très simple france
2030 qui a été présenté récemment sur
les questions de réindustrialisation sur
lequel il ya des enjeux de développement
durable et énergétique c'est 4 milliards
d'euros pour la loi de
la loi de programmation financière de
l'année prochaine 4 milliards d'euros
c'est même pas ce qu'a coûté la
suppression de l'sf sur le dernier
mandat d' emmanuel macron donc
sait rien on ne met pas les moyens
nécessaires et si on veut retrouver une
politique énergétique forte il faut
absolument commencer par renationaliser
edf et sortir du marché dérégulé de
l'énergie pour qu'on puisse que l'état
et les moyens de la puissance de l'état
pour pouvoir agir à la fois sur les prix
et sur les investissements aujourd'hui
c'est très compliqué en tout cas à
gauche à
on prône la sortie du nucléaire je vous
propose justement de jallet j'allais y
venir justement dans le détail je
n'allais jamais y venir je vous propose
de regarder les propositions des
candidats à la présidentielle à marine
le pen un qui veut rouvrir ça va vous
faire plaisir rwandair rouvrir
l'ancienne centrale nucléaire de
fessenheim retirer toutes les éoliennes
à elle va pas être contente marine le
pen parce qu'il ya eu l'annonçant à en
parler aussi si on a le temps de brader
des éoliennes également aujourd'hui
valérie pécresse lr eric zemmour
construire des nouveaux apn et puis je
le disais la gauche anne hidalgo
ps jean luc mélenchon et yannick jadot
la france insoumise sortir du nucléaire
avec évidemment les
écologistes christine taubira quand elle
veut remettre en place un référendum il
ya que finalement fabien roussel pcf qui
veut maintenir le nucléaire
ce sont vous êtes plutôt satisfait du
coup aujourd'hui toujours sur la même
ligne valérie pécresse et emmanuel
macron se rejoint en tout cas sur cette
question du nucléaire alors il ya deux
propositions dans le programme de la
grèce notamment sur le prix les
discussions au niveau européen comment
on arrive à avoir des contrats pour les
grandes entreprises consommatrices
d'énergie pour élever la compétitivité
du pays
yar sur les éoliennes grande différence
on le dit très concrètement et jouerait
parce que là aussi on tape les ruraux
les périodes robin il n'ya pas
d'éoliennes dans le 7e arrondissement
et ce sont des personnes qui acquièrent
un logement ils ont beaucoup de mal à le
vendre dans certaines zones parce que
dans le rural un petit peu reculer part
c'est plus difficile de vendre son
logement c'est leur seul bien et en art
en train de leur mettre une éolienne
contre l'avis de leur mère contre l'avis
de ces populations là est en train
d'évaluer leur bien la seule chose qui
possède la seule chose qu'ils peuvent
transmettre à leurs enfants et là on du
beau jeu c'est pas très grave c'est pas
très grave nous paris on est les bobos
on décide ben non c'est pas comme ça
qu'on respecte les gens c'est pas comme
ça qu'on respecte les français et moi je
voudrais vraiment que sur les éoliennes
parce qu'on a eu les gilets jaunes il
faut comprendre un moment que ces
français qui vivent dans le périurbain
dans llovera l'on doit un minimum les
respecte et il n'y a pas que les
métropoles alors je sais que la france
de même ma consoeur france 2 mai au pôle
c'est la france des gens qui peuvent
vivre qui vivent bien qu'ils ont trois
stations de métro quand ils descendent
de chez eux il ya des gens qui vivent
pas comme ça il ya des gens qui ont mis
toutes leurs économies dans une maison
ri quand leurs plantes une éolienne en
face ben oui sont pas contents et
j'aurais qu'on arrête cela voudrait
qu'on écoute les maires voilà monsieur
macron écoute les maires ça serait très
bien si vous pouvez lui transmettre le
message que j'ai cru comprendre que vous
étiez un vous étiez francs monsieur le
député européen donc si vous pouvez lui
transmettre d'écouter les maires quand
on leur dit quelque chose ça serait très
bien parce qu'il les a trouvés quand il
y avait du gilet jaune pour organiser
les débats donc forêt qui les écoute
quand il ya des problèmes l'éolienne je
voudrais vous faire oui je vais de vous
donner la parole mais je voudrais
d'abord vous faire écouter manuel macron
sur justement cette annonce sur les
éoliennes
l'éolien en mer sera développé pour
visée de l'ordre de 40 gigawatts en
service en 2050 soit une cinquantaine de
parcs éoliens en mer
dès cette année nous mettrons en
activité le premier parc éolien en mer
au large de saint nazaire
mais là aussi ce que nous avons commencé
de faire c'est de recréer déployer une
filière industrielle française
les usines du havre de saint nazaire de
cherbourg permettront de fournir tous
les équipements nécessaires et nous
allons continuer de développer là aussi
l'emploi industriel et les
investissements pour que ces choix fort
de l'éolien en mer soit accompagnée de
créations d'emplois partout sur notre
territoire
emmanuel macron sur ses annonces sur ces
fameuses éoliennes offshore et puis ce
message télégramme à l'instant qui fait
un peu sourire hellemmes soto qui vous
dit impossible de se passer du nucléaire
les énergies renouvelables et
alternatives sont largement suffisantes
face à nos besoins à moins de pédaler
pour faire tourner son et alien dans le
jardin claude brender c'est vrai que
cette question des éoliennes
elle suscite parfois les crispations
emmanuel macron tout à leur disait mais
non cela n'empêche pas la protection de
l'environnement du paysage votre avis
sur le sujet
écoutez je pense que tu tout et
complémentaires aucune énergie nette
ajustée mais bon pour pour autant il
faut rester raisonnable
aujourd'hui l'éolien peut avoir de
l'intérêt dans certaines odeurs dans
certaines régions pour recours pour
venir compléter le dispositif mais 100%
renouvelable et 100% intermittence et
pas possible donc on tout le monde le
sait et donc ensuite je pense que
l'énergie c'est vraiment un sujet
sérieux alors tout le monde un petit à
raison de des intervenants qui sont qui
sont arrivés aujourd'hui on a on
affaiblit effet edf seront sincères
d'edf pour pour la politique énergétique
et peut donc aller but électoraux
ensuite il faudrait peut-être arrêter le
ping pong des ddd au changement majorité
je change de stratégie énergétique
je pense que c'est pas ça pense que le
l'énergie est sérieux et devrait devrait
être inscrit quasiment de chez pas dans
la constitution faire un référendum
pourquoi pas mais mais qu'on arrête de
faire du ping pong au gré des
changements de majorité et je pense que
les financements si on parle de
financement investir dans le nucléaire
c'est bien moins cher que d'investir
dans l'éolien et au shore et autres
parler parce que bon derrière c'est
beaucoup plus 2 milliards qu'il faut
qu'il va falloir y mettre un panier
dataquest oui bien sûr mais alors
effectivement le monsieur le maire a
raison il peut avoir un intérêt
installer des parcs d'éoliennes offshore
bon même si je suis d'accord aussi sur
le fait qu'il faut écouter je suis moi
même élu local à un moment il faut on
peut pas utiliser les maires les
départements et les régions que quand on
en a besoin quand on
on doit travailler avec l'on doit les
écouter on doit entendre ce qu'ils
disaient les populations avaient elles
n'ont pas été écoutés effectivement mais
surtout moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
au delà de ces annonces on a aujourd'hui
des outils qui existent en france pour
pouvoir développer l'énergie
différemment je pense par exemple à
l'hydroélectrique et aujourd'hui nos
serres que de régulateurs de production
il est largement sous utilisé
on ne fait plus d'investissements dans
ce domaine en plus il est menacé par une
volonté de l'union européenne de
privatiser donc de vendre ces barrages
qui est très dangereux parce qu'on parle
beaucoup d'accidents nucléaires et 3
accident nucléaire majeur ont lieu dans
le monde deux étaient des entreprises
privées et après tchernobyl c'est un
sujet assez particulier mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que on a des moyens
avant de déclencher des milliards dans
des choses dont on ne sait pas bien
comment on va les retraités après parce
que ce ne sont pas des installations de
long terme donc on parle des déchets
nucléaires on ne sait pas comment on
retraite les éoliennes une fois qu'elles
ont arrêté de produire les installations
elles existent peut-être faudrait-il en
développer d'autres sur
l'hydroélectrique et je serais curieux
de voir d'ailleurs la réaction de
certains écologistes qui vont nous
expliquer que tel vallée tel endroit
peut pas être utilisé pour faire de
l'hydroélectrique alors que c'est une
énergie propre et que quand on va les
privatiser on voit les mêmes sur les
barrages pour les défendons mais il
aurait empêché de les faire il ya 50 ans
donc on est dans un paradoxe assez
intéressant mais là ça ne demande pas
des investissements massifs sa demande
de changer de politique et
d'organisation dans la priorité du mix
énergétique français et j'invite le
président à le faire et je pose la
question je m'associe à mon collègue
pour poser la question aux députés
européens et lui dire et il expliqué
emmanuel macron que deux au lieu de
faire des annonces qui sont électorale
on mène une vraie politique énergétique
dans ce pays et qu'ils en discutent avec
les français christophe grudler vous
allez passer le message emmanuel macron
d'écouté très volontiers mais je pense
qu'il n'a pas besoin je pense qu'il a
une vraie vision pour la france il y
avait une vraie vraie vision pour les
français une vraie vision énergétique et
c'est vraiment ce qu'il apportait
aujourd'hui à belfort qui n'ait accès
sûrement pas une métropole donc tout ne
se passe pas
en métropole c'est le vice-président
donc voilà ça j'y suis aussi attaché à
sa peut-être trois petites remarques
rapide sur les éoliennes moi je crois
plutôt à fond aux éoliennes et s'assure
de la fin et en mer on peut se retrouver
sur l'hydroélectrique le président s'est
engagé cet après midi à ce qu'il n'y ait
pas de mise en concurrence et donc il va
y avoir effectivement un bras de fer
avec bruxelles à ce sujet là avec la dg
comtal à la commission européenne mais
il ya un engagement qui a été pris parce
que l'hydro électrique c'est important
il ya effectivement moi je reçois à la
fois des ong qui me demande de faire des
grands barrages parce que c'est très
bien et puis d'autres qui disent non il
faut pas de barrages parce que c'est pas
bon pour la biodiversité donc il ya un
peu d'incohérences là dessus je suis
d'accord edf n'est pas faibli avec des
annonces qui sont fait du rachat des
turbines arabe et l des alternateurs edf
a maintenant maîtriser toute la chaîne
de valeur sur la production nucléaire ce
qui va lui permettre d'avoir des
partenaires aussi avec d'autres pays
dans le monde d'autres animations le
président de république a cité
d'ailleurs la russie puisqu'il ya des
désaccords très fort en vo atom et les
turbines à grabels qui fournissent déjà
une partie des ddd et centrales
nucléaires russes donc il ya un travail
de partenaires d'affaires et sur le
financement vous avez oublié quelque
chose il y a la taxonomie européenne qui
est là pour amener des financements
privés pour pousser les projets
nucléaires et qui peut y avoir dans
l'union européenne donc on a aussi des
leviers de financement européen pour ses
projets nucléaires merci vaste débat en
tout cas on le voit merci à tous les
quatre clubs brender anthony tâter
qu'aux élections de tous et et
christophe grudler d'avoir accepté donc
d'être avec nous pour décrypter ce
discours réagir au discours d' emmanuel
macron merci à vous